okay uh we have an example today this is
not me patting myself on the back but we
have an example today of exactly what I
warned you about a couple months ago
when I did a story about populism versus
social democracy I did a story called
social democracy is being destroyed by
populism this was a little while ago and
I warned you about how the rhetoric of
populism can sound very good
it can even sound like it's uniting left
and right in favor of the middle class
or whatever but that the language can so
easily be used to bamboozle and trick
people Trump used populist rhetoric in
2016
Trump tricked many on the right and some
on the left with his populist rhetoric
in 20 2016 and we are now seeing the
repercussions of that in the current
administration so I have an example for
you today from Tucker Carlson which is
exactly what I was warning about there's
more and more left wingers that are sort
of sympathetic to Tucker Carlson who's a
Fox News propagandist because Tucker has
been increasingly using the language of
populism which sometimes sounds
reasonable to hide his horrible policy
ideas sometimes Tucker you turn it on it
sounds like a white nationalist show and
then sometimes you turn it on like last
night or the night before and you here
Tucker using pretty uncontroversial
populist language which could be
implemented with right-wing policy or it
could be implemented with left-wing
policy and he did it again this week and
there are people on the people on the
right of course but there's even
leftists just gushing about look at the
common sense that we're hearing here
from Tucker Carlson and it's painful to
see people fall for it I warned you
about this in my segment recently let's
take a look at the clip forget that in
the end the Republican Party exists to
serve the interests of normal people
ordinary people middle-class families
are the core of this country they are
hope for the future our only hope and
yet both parties have shameless
we abandoned them middle-class families
have no national spokesman they have no
lobby in Washington Republicans pretend
to be their champion you know by now
that they are not instead of improving
the lives of their voters the party
feeds them a steady diet of mindless
symbolic victories partisan junk food
designed to make them feel full even as
they waste away who cares how many
Benghazi hearings we have we're supposed
to care why should we how did Peter
strux text messages become more
important than saving American jobs from
foreign nationals who are taking them it
is lunacy we fall for it every time and
to the extent this show has participated
in it we apologize with deepest
sincerity so this is classic populist
rhetoric that is very similar on the
left and right Federico Finkelstein from
the new school is very very good he's
one of the foremost experts on left
versus right wing populism and we have
looked at so many examples of rhetoric
that is populist rhetoric which sounds
like it could be coming from a leftist
or from a lunatic right winger the party
you know here Tucker is saying the
Republican Party should be serving the
middle class you hear Democrats
sometimes use similar rhetoric we should
be primarily serving the middle class
the middle class is the core of the
country politicians should focus on
improving the lives of voters he even
mentions Tucker does the silliness of
Benghazi hearing after Benghazi hearing
and Peter Struck's texts and it's true
that was nonsense jobs matter more like
he's saying things that are true but he
can't even suppress the right-wing
xenophobia he can't hold it back because
he says hey we we need the Republican
Party to protect us from foreign
nationals who have taken our jobs and
that's the bubbling up of that virulent
anti-immigrant Tucker Carlson that we
know who has said immigrants make our
country dirtier and poorer and this is
why the rise of populism on the left at
the exclusion of just a solid socially
democratic set of ideas is so
as I've said before social democracy is
less about rhetoric and it's more about
a clear set of policy ideas including
how do we get health care for everybody
finance education how do we tax people
well how do we do policing there's so
much policy in social democracy when
instead you start seeing populist
rhetoric it can come from the left and
right and it can sound pretty damn good
with no regard to the policies that are
actually being proposed so to be clear
you can have populist rhetoric and
socially Democratic policy okay both I
mean that would be fine but people like
Tucker Carlson and Steve Bannon to some
degree and others they're great at using
just the rhetoric to pull people in to
what in the end at the other side of it
you know they at the end of the rainbow
so to speak is a terrible set of policy
ideas and Tucker couldn't even hide his
dog whistle it's 95 percent reasonable
populist sounding rhetoric with foreign
nationals which basically means hey
we've got to keep those Mexicans out
right that that's what's the policy
prescription at the end of this so you
have to listen much more carefully
because it sounds good
we also shouldn't underestimate the
effect that Tucker's advertisers
abandoning him might be having on his
rhetoric I don't know that's another
story which we've covered Tucker's
having major problems with advertisers
because of some of the white nationalist
type sounding rants maybe this is
posturing for those purposes I don't
know but the point the idea here is
listen to all my populist sounding
rhetoric but my solutions are xenophobia
to support the middle class
stop immigrants from coming in so on and
so forth as someone said to me on
Twitter this is a shadow tactic it
sounds reasonable you pull them in with
the rhetoric then you drop the seed of
populism when you think no one is
looking and then it's hey you know what
you'd better vote for Republicans or
black lives matter is going to come and
take your house right that's though
that's the bamboozle that's the bait and
switch that happens in the end this is a
polished way to tell us Mexicans are
stealing our jobs black lives matter is
going to take your house
and we need to stop everybody so don't
fall for this stuff review that clip
that I did about populism and social
democracy because this was exactly
there's no better example of this type
of ruse that I warned you about six
weeks ago or whenever I did that story
then in this Tucker Carlson segment let
me know what you think I'm on twitter at
des Pakman remember that you can get the
entire show in our audio podcast form
every single day you can get it on
whatever your favorite podcasting app is
whether it's iTunes or pod catcher or
whatever else
Spotify etc get that daily audio podcast
let me know what you think about this
populism social democracy ruse on
Twitter where you can find me at D
Pakman if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink it's blink Isleta consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video